after i don't know maybe a couple of few
months she become muslim
and then her sister become muslim
and then her mom become muslim and then
my dad become muslim and then my mom
become muslim
and then so there was this this little
like ripple effect this little spread
[Music]
[Music]
effect
[Music]
um
think about a video game think about a
movie you think about a book
you have different characters the
character
is uh the expressions the actions
the personality the traits of this
individual
good character would imply obviously
that this person leads
towards good bad would imply that they
lean towards bad but
having character in general uh implies
authenticity or at least
i would say good character implies
authenticity
dear brothers and sisters you were
joined here today with the three muslims
and my brother michael how you doing
brother
i'm good brother how you doing people
call me dowie people call me dowie bro
dowie yeah yeah i need to please call me
michael any everyone else calls me dowie
all right all right let's say less and
dowie we are here with
dowie all right don't mess that up only
the police call
michael y'all get it but without further
ado
we want to get right into your story bro
because you've been a reaver for 25
years now correct
yeah yeah 25 i just because i've been 25
ramadan
so that's uh that's how i call it yeah
yeah yeah
since me since yeah so i've become
muslim during ramadan so that's easy for
me to count you know
so you became a muslim during ramadan
yeah during ramadan yeah
because it was like in the winter you
know so it was yeah kind of yeah it's
kind of easy
okay so forgive me for my ignorance here
i haven't seen
any of your videos or anything like that
but
for anyone else who hasn't as well like
what's your story look like bro
okay um so we want me to take it from
the top board bro
take it away all right okay bismillah so
um about 25 years ago um like i said i
i was i had a son my first child and
then i thought
you know you know you go through that i
think having kids even makes you a man
or breaks you as a man
you know you either step up or you step
out you know so i thought
it's time for me to um you know
change my life and and look for and you
know look for a higher purpose or
or a bigger meaning of life so i was
always kind of interested in religion i
always had a religious belief although i
didn't have a religion
so i always believed in god but i didn't
even know i grew up as as
we might call loosely speaking a
christian in a christian family
we would only go to church if he was
getting buried or getting married we
wouldn't
practice any christianity and i mean so
i used to have in my where i live i was
like a hill like a small hill
um and i used to go there and pray
before i knew anything about muslims or
religion or anything i used to go there
and pray and i would sort of
point up to the sky and just pray okay
whenever i needed something normally to
complain to be honest you know so
i i made a promise that i would go
looking for god he wouldn't
come looking for me i would go looking
for him
so i set about this this sort of journey
to go looking for god
so obviously i spoke to christians i
spoke to jehovah's witnesses
hindus buddhists like i said i don't
know any jewish people
just because they just don't live around
my areas so as i would have spoke to
them as well
i spoke to various different types of
people and
but not so much muslims you know muslims
sort of kept themselves
to themselves you know what i'm saying i
tried a few times to get them to come
around my flat
my apartment where i was uh living to
come and speak to me about it but they
sort of let me let it down so eventually
after the third time of them not coming
i i decided to go to the mosque
and ask my questions there so i
it was during ramadan but i didn't
really clock things ramadan you know i
mean so
i said to myself i know this muslim
people this muslim lot they don't drink
alcohol
so out of respect to go to their mosque
i won't drink alcohol for three days
before i go to make myself sort of clean
i know three days isn't a lot of time
but for me back then it was
it was a bit of time so i went there and
um
i started sat down and started because i
only went there to speak about the
crucifixion of jesus
you know what i mean because for us for
me it was like natural that he was
crucified
because that's what we've been brought
up listening to so
i went in there to ask this question and
i sat down with
an arab brother um and we got talking
and he explained it to me
then he explained about tolheed and et
cetera except you know
certain basic fundamentals and i just
that was me i was done
i i i found it you know i found that
that that answers that i was looking for
that feeling that i wanted i'd found it
so
i'm too much harder then i i uh took my
shahada
in the masjid that moment that day and i
fasted the next day
and i never drunk alcohol since then you
know what i mean so
that that's like the the the um the the
the sort of quick version of how i
become muslim all this took
probably about a year you know if you
used to
take it from beginning you know but
hold on now hold on you said you said
that you got the feeling you were
looking for what exactly
were you looking for here you know like
i said brother i mean i i've always
believed that there was a god
but i i couldn't put him into any
particular religion or category
but when i used to go and pray i would
just pray to god i would just go
stand on a hill and just pray just point
up to the sky and pray
but i didn't believe jesus was god even
though i was brought up in a christian
um sort of you know culturally christian
you know i'm saying
i was brought up culturally christian i
didn't believe that jesus was a was god
i just believed there was a god so and i
knew that i had to find
that that god i knew that i had to find
that god and i didn't think it would be
islam because
islam would be the religion that if you
was to step back and look at every
religion individually
you'd pick at least because it means you
can't have a girlfriend you can't go out
drinking
there's lots of things that you can't do
as a muslim so you'd look at them and
say well that one's difficult i'm not
going to do that
whereas something like christianity or
buddhism or something is a lot easier
you know you have a lot more
what you would think are our freedoms
you know so
i didn't go looking for islam i just
went looking for god
and i went to the masjid i went to the
mosque that day and uh
didn't go there with the intention of
becoming muslim the people that i met
there definitely didn't think i was
going to become muslim
and um that was enough because i think
sincerity
and the truth are very compatible
they're very like a marriage in it so if
someone's actually sincere in what
they're talking about
and you tell them the truth you know i
mean they're going they're gonna they're
gonna take to that it's gonna
them two things are gonna then two
things are gonna come together you know
i think i think it is true that what a
lot of converts and rebirth say that
like
the last time that they drank they
didn't know it would be the last time
they drank
you know what i mean yeah defoe because
i used to drink like every you know
most days every day so to me it was
normal you know
drinking for us as in as in a white
family in the uk
i don't know about america and that but
it was normal you know like
for me to drink as a young kid eight
seven or eight years old
in my house was normal my dad would call
me downstairs when he had his friends
around for a drink
and he'd get a glass of whiskey and he'd
pour the whiskey in the glass i was only
about nine or ten
and he'd make me drink it just so he
could show his mates that his son could
drink you know what i mean
and um so my mum used to put whiskey in
my bottle to help me sleep
you know so little nipple whiskey in the
bottle when you're a baby to obviously
so these things we've gone back into the
1970s when we're going back
a long time where things were different
you know i mean but yeah
if you'd have told me then when you go
to this mosque you're not going to drink
for the rest of your life i probably
would have ran away
but i didn't go there thinking that you
know what i mean
so hum did i don't miss it
so bro when you went in there and you
asked some you said uh about the
crucifixion
of jesus christ peace be upon him what
did they say
they said that it wasn't actually jesus
that was crucified it was a man that was
looked like him
okay and the likeness of jesus was put
on this man and he was crucified and
jesus was taken up to heaven
the second heaven in order to come back
and finish his job
his task his mission and so he spoke to
me about that
which kind of made more sense than jesus
was crucified for sins
that that he never committed you know
like that god had to have a son
then sacrificed that son to forgive me
so it wasn't it wasn't such a big
it was just the case that it was a
different narrative than what i've ever
heard before i've never really heard
anyone
challenge that you know i've never heard
anyone challenge the crucifixion they're
not saying so
um but like i wasn't as devout christian
so it made more sense to me that he
wasn't crucified you know
so was that like what did it for you or
was it
no but it was it was more the rest of it
you know i mean it was more the
it was more him talking about there
being one god and praying to that god
and believing in the angels and the
books and breaking down
the the the the history of the bible and
the old testament
so just he didn't go into massive detail
and i think that's important when you're
giving dawah you've got to sort of
you know it takes more wisdom than
knowledge to give dawah you know what
i'm saying so
it is it's okay whacking people with
loads of knowledge but if they're not
absorbing it
you give them what they can absorb you
give them what they can take on
you know and some people don't need a
lot if it's the truth
they don't need a lot of it to accept it
or to recognize it you know i mean
if it's the truth it's the truth they
don't need to know volumes of books
they just need to be hear the truth and
then the rest of it will flow you know
what i mean
man that's true and like sometimes i'll
catch myself getting like overly excited
where it's like i want to share more
than i need to when i have to stop
myself and be like yo
they probably don't need that much they
probably just need
one little snippet and like let it let
it go with them
if it's gonna if it's gonna grow and
it's gonna allow them to
realize what it is alhamdulillah and if
it's not well alhamdulillah like a lot
of
guys who we wills you know exactly bob
you know i'm saying sometimes you don't
need to go
and i think that's just over keen and
zealousness from from muslims where they
just want to tell
you everything because i suffered a lot
from that when i first become muslim
everyone every muslim then after i spoke
to thought that it was their duty to
educate me you know and you had got
loads of different opinions coming at
you and
do this this way and do this that way
because they think because you're a
revert that
it's their job now to to tell you
everything that they know about islam
which can be overwhelming it can be
confusing you know i mean
oh yeah okay it can be a little bit sort
of like overpowering
so i i tend now from experience i tend
now just to gauge the person
some people you it's sometimes it's more
important to say a little but mean a lot
than it is to say a lot and get lost in
it you know i mean people just forgot
what you said 10 minutes ago
you're not me 100
so bro that was you reverting
coming to islam becoming muslim so what
what do the next years look like
i don't know where they're going to come
brother you know what i mean for me now
um i mean
i'm 51 so if i'm i mean i'm in a stage
of my life now i'm more
focused on helping than i ever have been
okay
simply because i feel like i'm coming to
the end
i'm not that i'm ill or i don't know
that i'm ill or i'm not an illness or
anything like that but
i'm not going to live another 51 years i
mean i could i could i could live 51
years you could live to 102
but most likely the average age is about
80 283 in it or something so
i need to do something now brother i
mean i need to do something now
to help to input to make a difference i
need to do
when i stand in front of allah on
judgment day i need to have something
you know i mean
and i need to tell people what it is or
show people what it is that i can
even if it's this much at least i can
stand there and say i did this much
you know so i kind of have i'm kind of
feeling that um
urgency to sort of help and i've been a
muslim i'm not a scholar or anything
obviously you can tell but 25 years in
the religion now it gives me an
insight that people that have been in
the dean two or three years don't have
yet
you know they're still young they're
still they still got changes to make so
if i can even pass down some of those
experiences and
um life life um
life experiences to them then that's
something you know what i mean
inshallah i'm good bro i was i was
referring to
what happened in the years after
reverting oh sorry
from this minute yeah you you're good
though i i want to know about what
what you're talking about here what you
want to do to help but before we get
into that
tell me what happened after you reverted
like what led to this point
right okay so when i reverted i had a
girlfriend um i was living with
my girlfriend in a what we call a flat
you call an apartment and
after a couple of weeks it was become
clear to me that i couldn't stay
in that apartment with her okay so then
i moved back to my mum and dad's house
which was only up the road
and um i kept in contact with her
obviously because we had a child
together with a newborn baby together at
that point
so then i just started to learn i really
learned how to pray uh i was going to
the to the masjid on a daily basis you
know every day i would hit there for at
least isha
denise the last prayer when i got home
from work and
after i don't know maybe a couple of few
months she become muslim
and then her sister become muslim
and then her mom become muslim and then
my dad become muslim and then my mum
become muslim
and then so there was this this little
like ripple effect this little spread uh
effect so we ended up not me and this uh
woman we ended up not getting married
um we decided that it was the best move
for either one of us but we still
maintain a sort of friendly friendly
relationship contact you know
and then she went off and got married to
a um
another muslim man um which was which
was fine then her sister
her sister's boyfriend become muslim and
then they got married
so i kind of uh i don't know i mean
it was just a case of i just went on
this journey so after this
i i was living at mum and dad's house
and then you know it would be like
my dad would go you know about six
o'clock half past five six in the
morning my dad would
get to come out the bedroom and go to
the toilet you know as and then he would
see my bedroom light on and the door
opened just a little bit and he could
see like see me sort of praying fajr
so that's what that's what intrigued my
dad and then my mom in order to
ask questions and be muslim it's not
it's not so much sitting down and having
long deep conversations about religion
it was more a case of the change in
personality and the change in
in me so um
so yeah so that was that then i then i
went off and got my own place
and um some years later i got married
myself
unfortunately just that marriage did 16
years 17 years
it didn't work out unfortunately and um
but i had three
three children off of that's that woman
and um
from then on bro i've just been i've
just i've gone through different phases
though you know i mean i mean i've gone
through
you know when you're a new muslim you
kind of go it's like jumping into a
river and just getting
swayed down sometimes you kind of mix in
with certain people in certain groups
and they
go down a little bit with them and then
so i in the beginning
i was with a a group called um
the tablikis and
no disrespect i don't want to get
involved in any arguments of any groups
and then i went with them and after a
couple of years out of
being with them i went into another
group these guys are more selfie
and then now i just sort of keep myself
sort of balanced by myself you know i
don't
i don't really affiliate too strongly
with anybody i just
just practice the religion basically
brother i mean
if you feel like you want to listen the
floor is yours
brother i could talk to england you know
that
but you can ask me questions but
probably better otherwise i just won't
shut up
yeah yeah okay yeah okay so um
romney if i do you guys have anything
you want me to jump in i was gonna ask
subhanallah about how
you said you gauge people when you when
you discussed with them and i think
that's
honestly the most important thing that's
something that even hanzo sources and
other people have mentioned on this
podcast
um you know gauging people going with
the blank canvas
so is there any specific
uh memories you have or any specific
cases or people that send out to you
when you have done this or do you have
any tips on how muslims because
that was you know obligatory upon
everyone right do you have any tips for
how muslims should approach that with
reverts or with non-muslims um i mean i
i can i can kind of speak more from
from from the inside of being a white
white was a white reaver and a white
muslim
you know what muslim reverts generally
going to have a lot of similarities be
then black or white or whatever but
from from a white from a white
perspective from from that insight i
think
the the main thing is is you see what i
notice is that
when muslims ever do anything wrong
non-muslims will jump on it and blame
the religion
i see muslims are drinking our muslims
are doing this and muslims but they will
never ever do that when it comes to
christianity or any other religion for
that matter what i'm saying so if you
see a christian doing something wrong
you never
oh you christians do this or you
christians are not meant to do that
but they will do that with muslims
because i believe that instinctively
they know that islam is the truth
so when they see a muslim doing
something that's not right
i don't know whatever it is but so they
will quickly jump on that
so the best dollar that you can give is
to is your behavior is your character
and your manners
because people notice that you can talk
all your life you can give it all of
this
but if you do something wrong they will
they'll be on that you know i mean
so for me the best form of doubt is good
character and good manners because that
that that that's the first thing that
people will jump on with muslims if they
see a muslim doing anything wrong it's
oh your religion doesn't i thought
you're not meant to do this you're not
meant to do that it never happens with
any other religion when is the last time
you heard
someone say about christians not meant
to have a girlfriend
or anything you know so character i mean
and just conducting yourself with
manners and decency is is that
and then when it comes to gauging the
person some people you know
they don't really they don't they don't
need to know loads and loads i mean
if you talk to someone for more than
five or ten minutes most people start to
sort of get a little bit overwhelmed at
that point
not all but most you know especially the
guys that i know so
five or ten minutes of something
powerful and something meaningful
is better than an hour and a half of too
much of something they can't digest
but the first thing i would say bruv is
conduct yourself because they're always
watching you
you know if once they know you're a
muslim and they see you doing something
wrong
they're attaching that behavior to your
to our religion
so we've got to represent you know we've
got we've got a responsibility as
muslims to represent the religion
no matter what you know
yeah i'm over here right now by the way
uh visiting my dad and my little brother
and my dad's wife
my stepmom and you know like i'm
i'm still new so i'm still trying to
like uh
learn to not curse i think cursing was
one of like my biggest flaws
i used to curse very much and i used to
be very sexual
in my jokes and just i so happy i'm just
trying not to like do it as much
the brothers you know and um when i'm
coming over here spending time with my
family i'm like
oh like they're watching me yeah like
they're watching every little move i do
everything i say because like
without me realizing it my actions and
the way that i just speak and everything
has changed
but it's like there are still certain
things that i'm like
carrying with me from my uh ignorance
days my jahiliyyah days
and it's like i can't afford to have
that in front of them
when they're at um they're at like a
turning point
in sha allah they're at a turning point
where they will accept the deen they
will accept islam
but it's like man like they're watching
every little
thing and like i got i wake up every
single morning i read the quran
i pray and then i'm just like i'm
meditating as i mentioned i'm like
you know i gotta be on my best behavior
i gotta be on my a game here
not just for them but also for the
creator because the creator is always
watching us but like more so for them
right now because like they're the ones
in my vicinity
watching my actions and how i speak and
everything so
that speaks volumes bro i speak volumes
but is it strange that brothers um that
it doesn't happen with any other
religion
no other no person any other religion is
put under that type of pressure
you know muhammad allah chooses the
people that he knows can deal with it
and handle it so
and and you've got to remember brother
um you're human you're going to slip we
all slip we all slide and we none of us
are perfect
as long as you're trying and your family
understand that this is a this is an
ongoing effort this is a this is never a
finished
finish there's never everyone end game
it's just a journey you're not saying so
you're never going to be the end product
you're just going to be working on
yourself all the way through
but i mean i don't know how long you've
been muslim but i mean
in in i work in construction and the
the the language in that in that world
bro
it's colorful you know i mean it's
proper colorful
so i've only been muslim for
closing in on a year now alhamdulillah
definitely don't experience what you
experience when you're going to work
into the construction field i know
people
can get pretty pretty out of hand out
there
it's kind of like the the restaurant
industry
you know the way that they speak to each
other and the way they interact and all
that
uh but yeah man anyways anyways uh a
question that i have for you
uh being you you had mentioned that you
you know you're
you're white muslim white river uh have
you felt that it's been different for
you
like the way you've been treated and
like your acceptance
by the uh uma the the community
and just other practicing brothers and
sisters
okay from the muslim community it does
vary you know brother i mean there is
uh i mean it's i mean over the period of
25 years i've noticed a lot of changes
even within the muslim community
because when i first became muslim them
years ago
a lot of the older people in the in the
uh the older uncles in the masjid were
just
were just just didn't get it you know i
mean they just sit there and stare at
you in the mosque
they'd sit on the floor and they would
just look at you and you'd look at them
and they'd just keep staring at you
because i just don't think that they
understood it um
so but that's obviously over the time
over decades that that sort of
that changes but unfortunately there's
not
there's not there's something is there's
something not quite change
crossing over between the muslim
community and the non-muslim white
people
it's just that that bridge isn't quite
complete yet you know what i mean
because you know i can go to a masjid
i'm up i'm in a town in
in in england called luton which is
quite diverse he's got like different
cultures
different ethnic cultures and everything
else so i go into a masjid
and i will see everybody from malaysia
from
arabia from africa from everywhere but
you might not not see one english person
not one white english person sorry and
that's
that's been a while now you know there
is obviously white english music but
there's not enough so it is changing and
there is progress but the progress is
it seems to be a little slow you know
gotchu so in regards to
non-muslims how do they react when they
find out that you're a muslim
surprise initially you know initially
they're like what what do you mean
you're muslim you're muslim and then
they start saying it deliberately starts
saying it wrong so they can
you know um try and get a reaction out
of you so sometimes a surprise
then after a little while when when they
sort of know that you're serious about
it then they might ask the odd question
and then they'll say well what about
this and what about that what about the
women wearing this and what about
you know then they genuinely want to
know i mean i've noticed in the last
three or four years at work i mean it's
changed
it's changed i mean you know i don't
know what's changed it or how
what's what's pushed that forward but
the the people on that work now seem to
have a lot more interest in actually
knowing about islam
and you and we're talking about your
stereotypical white
working builder construction worker who
you would never
think he's going to have the slightest
they don't know much about islam but
they definitely
start to ask questions about it because
i remember when i first became muslim
after september 11th
9 11 there was a massive um
uh pushback
negative um vibe going against muslims
everywhere at that point you know
but now i in the last three years
because i've i mean at work i've had
i've had actual fights at work with um
about being a muslim you know i'm saying
so
i've had physical fights so but just
recently
that the people there they seem to be a
lot more inquisitive and i'm not asking
a lot
more questions um i don't know maybe
that's because i'm older and i and i
approached them differently
you know um could be that but i just
i've just found that but some people
initially when they find out you're
muslim they're surprised and then they
go through this period
it's just a phase in six months or a
year this feather will be finished with
this and it'll be on to the next thing
you know i mean
and then when they see after a while
that you're serious and that you're and
you're into it
um then they start to become accepted
but the mistake that i made when i first
became muslim is that i tried
to tell every all of my friends all of
my norms and friends too much too
quickly
and then if they didn't agree with me i
would just cut them off i
you know you're a non-muslim i'm not
gonna you know that's it i can't help
you you can't help me and i just used to
just drop them out you know just cut
them off which was a mistake that was
immature you know that that was just me
not understanding you know because what
i should have done is kept them around
to a point not socialize with them and
stuff but kept them around in order to
help them
because if you shut someone off brother
you can't help them you know but if you
keep a contact with them even if it's on
your terms obviously i'm not going to go
drinking with them and all that
but i can keep contact with them on my
terms in order to to help them along you
know
so but this is just a learning curve for
me there was no one out there teaching
me this it's just
things i had to learn in life you know
that's interesting man
the one thing um i find you know with
myself a lot nowadays
even being a born muslim someone i'm i'm
basically a reaver because you know i
was muslim by the name alhamdulillah but
i didn't start practicing 2016. i think
a lot of muslims go through that
nowadays but one thing i find is
subhanallah
there's a there's that learning curve
for all of us because of the
culture of the societies we live in
right like oh no you talk about swearing
and making certain jokes
that's just normal nowadays for a lot of
people
even me like jokes i make like they're
sometimes they're at the expense of
other people sometimes they're crude
sometimes they're very disrespectful
that's just what humor is like nowadays
and it's so difficult because
you know good character is not something
that's preached in general
and that's why that that's also you know
plays a role in how
effective it is when you have good
character because not only is it
something that's beautiful for
a human to witness in someone else it's
something that is very
very rare it's kind of love and
can you imagine if if all muslims if
every muslim
was giving dawa in this way where they
gauge the other person
and you know they they took a step back
to really analyze a person rather than
spew information at them
i feel like we've come a lot farther as
muslims and i don't think the media
would be able to keep up in in how they
try and make us seem
i just i honestly think it's it's crazy
upon allah
i mean i mean i'm engaging the person
brother that just has to come with
experience you can't expect
to know that all the time you know you
can't expect to just have this insight
and this knowledge you have to
that has to sort of grow on you even if
someone tells you you've still got to
practice it you still got
you've still got to live with it but um
yeah it just i mean
in the white culture in in england uh
like i said i can only speak from my
position
jokes are and banter is like
culture to us that's that's how we deal
with everything i've been at funerals
and people are cracking jokes you know
because that's just how they deal with
life you know what i mean
you know you go around your mate's house
and tell them that you misses has just
kicked you out they'll make a joke out
of it
you know you know it's just it's just
that's just the way it is and sometimes
you have to get around that
but um i think the problem that
new reverts have is that they
is that they tend to lose themselves a
little bit sometimes they tend to try
and change too much of themselves too
quickly
and then they kind of get a bit confused
about actually who they are now
you know because it takes some years to
learn this stuff it takes it takes time
to live this out
you have to live islam it's not
something that you you know it's
something that
is it's a journey isn't it so and so
they tend to take on you know they they
look different they talk different they
walk different they eat different
and then at some point they become they
they simply lose their own identity
and then they then they start panicking
and think well the only way i'm gonna
find myself again
is to leave the religion because i've
changed so much i don't recognize myself
or their family and friends saying oh
look at you now you look totally
different or you act differently
so so they tend to put on this now
they've become a muslim if they've
reverted to islam
and they've now they're going to put on
they think that they have to invent a
character
or become a different person in order to
be a muslim no brother you've got to be
yourself
you can be you you can maintain your
culture your identity your personality
and be muslim as as long as certain
aspects of your culture and personality
that are negative
you can work on getting rid of the rest
of you you keep
you know so you can have a laugh and a
joke with people you can have
as long as it stays within the
boundaries and perimeters that islam
would allow
you can be you i've seen so many new
muslims revere muslims come in the
religion they're strong
they're practicing two years later
they're done they're gone
a year two three years boom they're gone
you don't see them again why because
they was too much too quick
you know islam is like a marathon you've
got to pace yourself
you've got to be in this for the long
game you could die tomorrow we could die
in a moment's time but you could also
live another 60 70 years
yeah so if you're in this for the long
game you have to try and pace yourself
and um and not not rush through it you
know and not try and make too many
changes
too quickly you know i used to have a
beard down here
it was really long at one point but the
police kept stopping me
they just kept stopping me all the time
i'd go to the airport and the police
would just
they'd pull me over you know and i was
flying to morocco at that point
probably once a month and they would
just tell you straight
but um yeah so what i'm saying about you
don't um
i i would advise people to take it at
their pace some people are naturally
faster than others and that's fine
but some people they they think that
they have to identify themselves and
dress a different way and start wearing
phobes and start doing this and
start behaving completely differently to
what they normally would and then they
get confused they even start to confuse
themselves you know i mean
yeah so so so bro why do you think
that this happens a lot with rebirth do
you think it's something that you know
we as a community kind of push on them
and that we're do you think perhaps
we're a bit intolerant to them and how
they are
and we push for them to make these
changes
um i don't think it's that muslims are
intolerant of of it i think they just
you know muslims want the the new
muslims to be like them to be
part of the the the the the family as it
were
um you know so obviously putting a phobe
on them and everything else is
is part of the identity so now you're
like this is sort of like
i don't think there's any bad intention
about it i just think there's a lack of
um you know there's a little lack of
wisdom in it sometimes you know um so i
don't think that muslims say
they're intolerant i just think that
they they're over eager to get them in
and and um and make them part of the
the um and the family as it were um i
just think that for some people
they must know their limits and they
must pace themselves you know it don't
it's better to move slowly but all the
time then it is run and then stop
you know yeah sorry i i find that
it's kind of weird
[Music]
i think i've seen your videos yeah
because yeah i think you had one where
you were on the construction site you
were
giving dawah to uh one of the other
workers
and they had said that um oh
i can't i can't accept or not that i
can't accept but
it's like i i'm i don't think god would
accept me or something like that or
i was like i think yeah because what he
said is that because of all the bad that
goes on in the world yeah yeah
there's no god there there yeah yeah
yeah yeah i've seen you bro i've seen
you now that was my one bro
what happened there is someone took the
video off of my channel
and then they jigged it around and sort
of put the subtitles to it
and then put it out on other channels so
that's how you've probably seen it it's
from other places
because i i don't know anything about
cutting and editing and all that bro
i'll just hold the phone there and talk
you know that's
that's that's not my forte yeah but that
was that was that was uh yeah that was
me
so how's he doing did he uh is he asking
more questions
um you see that's another thing that i
used to do but when i become
he's asking questions yeah to answer
your question his arms he is asking
questions
but i don't really see it as um i have
to convince him
i just have to be out stand in front of
allah and judgment saying say i tried
that's it whether he becomes a muslim or
anybody becomes a muslim
i don't have that that um that control
but it could be that he will never
become muslim but people that watch that
video will become muslim
that's in their hands and their plan of
allah that's not in mind you know what i
mean
so my job is just it's just to try and
put it out there
um i think that's another problem when
people are so keen to
convince people to become muslim it
probably should your job to tell them
you know it's just your job to inform
them the best way you can
and if the best way you can is just with
a little bit of knowledge and and
and uh good and good behavior and good
character then
then do that you know then don't do that
you know but he's asking questions his
friend
that not in that video but he's got a
friend that works on the site he's
asking more questions than him
um but like i said
if they become muslim alhamdulillah but
that's not down to me you know i mean
that's that's not that
that's not down to me sometimes you can
affect people's lives and not even know
it
people you've never met you affect them
and then
it's not down to me you know i mean so
darwin have you ever felt like this urge
to just want to guide everyone to islam
brother i want to put my arms around the
whole world and guide everybody
you know yeah i really do but like i
said the the best way to
see even the processing wanted to do
this but and there was people that he
couldn't help
so what chance have i got in helping
everybody
i mean if he couldn't even do it so i'm
not going to be able i'm not even a
speck of him
you know not even a dot so um
i but i do get that feeling and i panic
for people
you know i feel bad i panic i think mate
in 50 60 whatever years you're going to
be dead
you know and you're going to have to
stand there and because i can sort of
see what they can't see you know
i know the future i'm not saying that
but i can i know that there's going to
be a judgment day
and in that judgment day they're going
to have to answer for everything that
they're doing now like we all will win
it
so i panic and i'm just sort of like a
bit you know please
just just save yourself in it you know
please become muslim but it's not down
to me man
i'm you know it's down to it's down to
all i stand to god i'll just try
but like i have a more of a passion now
or more of a um
i think a more of a mission now because
i'm because i'm getting older
you know because no i'm not old in it
but i'm getting older so i just want to
help
and i see a void between um
the youth and the ill you know it used
to be in the old days that
in times gone by that the elders would
pass knowledge down
and wisdom down to the young the younger
generation it's not happening anymore
it's not happening enough so who fills
that void
youtube music drugs this this this
hate preachers of different things they
feel the void that the elders should be
passing down wisdom to so i just feel
like you know i'll try and do my bit on
that one but
if if it was up to me but there'd be
certain very close friends of mine that
i would
love to become muslim and they and to
this day they still haven't
on that on that point do you think that
we're do you think that there's a
shortage of
traditional learning because you said we
don't have so much of the elders
teaching the youngsters
so do you think we're locking in um the
traditional learning kind of like the
chef
you know teaching the students and all
of that
yeah yeah definitely yeah yeah there's a
lack of that
there's also um there's also a problem
where i think the younger generation now
where we've got they've got social media
and
facebook and instagram there's so many
other distractions yeah you know it's
not it's not like in the old days you
know
yeah yeah subhanallah and i um see this
also creates a new layer this is
something that i went through as well
where it's like
we use the social media as our teacher
so
and we apply the dean in the aspect as
well so we know now we're learning islam
online
from social media and that that was
really beautiful for me at the beginning
but um it becomes really stagnant after
a while
if channels like merciful servant you
know kind of became stagnant because the
the creator
um you know was going through some stuff
and not just that but how do you know
everything you're learning is
actually you know coherent and
islamically valid
um and something i learned from actually
sitting and learning the traditional
sense with an actual
you know islamic teacher and everything
is it's that the transformation that we
go through is just not the same
it is not the same it's like it's
superficial um you know surface value
knowledge
and growth that you get from you know
learning online and stuff
versus back when they didn't have it you
were forced to sit down and read or you
were forced to sit down with the teacher
and actually learn under you know that
individual so that's something that
like it i feel it it's really
heartbreaking that you know we don't
have that so
it's kind of allah i urge you know all
the youngsters and everyone you know
similar to myself to go and actually you
know find a teacher
even if you have to really search for it
and learn under them insha allah
but subhanallah so have you have you had
that kind of traditional learning or
what was your education in islam like
okay yeah um
so i used to just go to the masjid broth
and and sit and listen to classes
i had another brother that i would go to
around his house and he would help me
learn to read arabic
and then we would do we'd go through the
books you know the books of taheed and
and everything else
so for me you know you you're you're
bang on bro because
when you're with somebody the energy
that you get sitting there listening to
them
is completely different to a screen you
know it's completely different to being
online and typing stuff so
i i definitely urge um younger
anybody not even young muslims or
muslims to go to if they're mastering is
doing classes go to the classes
if they're doing quran classes do them
if we're going listen you know go and
sit in with people because
not only that bro you know we need to be
around human beings
we we need to be around each other to
feel that we're part of the same ummah
the part
part of the same people you know i mean
so yeah
definitely social media and youtube and
all these things
has as two sides to it some one side's
really good and the other side
you know is a hindrance but if you can
get and sit face to face with someone to
teach you
do that definitely definitely i i'd
prefer that method you know i mean
so so that we when you were learning
islam do you think that there is a
proper order in terms of what you learn
because one
one brother actually he lives um very
close to me may allah bless him you're
telling me he has a fifth class right
he learns fifth and everything and at
first i was like you know is it is it
good that he's learning
before he learns you know al-qaeda and
all of that and then as he started
explaining it you know they explain
like like basically how to pray how to
do hajj these very basic things
that's what that's what is so
with your experience and how you were
learning do you do you think that there
is
something that muslims should really
focus in on first if they haven't
really had that traditional learning or
do you think they should just jump in
and whatever class inshallah they can
get their hands on
uh it's not wise to jump in i don't
think on any class you get your hands on
i think what
what you must learn to do is is learn
the basics of the religion
the the pillars of faith and the pillars
of the deen uh
definitely learn to heed learn to pray
um
understand what you're saying when
you're praying um because the the most
powerful thing about islam is tolhee
you know and um and learning that
correctly and
that to me is and there's always going
to be brothers that want to get you know
a little bit more technical and go into
fifth and then go into
learning hadith and stuff like that and
that will be depend on the individual
but if you don't learn your basics in
anything in life you're gonna you're
gonna fall you're gonna fall over at
some point
yeah saying if you you've got you've
gotta get the basics right before you
can move on
and if it takes you a hundred years to
learn the basics
so what yeah i mean it's not a race some
people are going to learn quicker than
others
but as long as you're trying but you
know for me but i've just been a basic
muslim
is is is is is a lifelong
journey it's a it's an everyday thing
you know
and um so i i would i would uh always
say start with the basics ground
yourself
in the basics because when i've been a
bit rocky on the dean
and you know you go from 25 years you go
through phases
it's been that grounding that i had in
the beginning where i learned the basics
of my religion
what's held me down that stopped me from
leaving
had i have not had that and that i've
gone into other arguments and other
issues
then maybe i would have been drifted off
in and left the religion at some point
but because i had a grounding
of basics i um that that sort of kept me
kept me in kept me in the game you know
carefully grounded right
and then it kept me grounded it kept me
you know it it just it's
just something in me that believes in
that yeah you know
just i just like people say don't you
miss drinking alcohol anymore
no i don't because why because it's a
sin
and if it and the guilt and the feeling
that i know that i would get from
drinking alcohol now
and you know committing a sin against my
allah would outweigh any feeling i'd get
from the alcohol
you'll never feel never be the same
again you could never go back
and because i learned these basics about
tolheed and about these things
back in 25 years ago then
it's it's kept me solid it's given me
like a foundation of the house
you know sometimes the windows are
dropped out and the roof's got a hole in
it but the foundations are solid you
know what i mean
yeah and then it's alhamdulillah i've
managed to i've managed to hold it you
know
subhan allah may love bless you bro i'm
so happy you mentioned that
i'm so happy you mentioned that because
when i first started that traditional
learning allah
we're talking like literally for like
first like 20 minutes of class
what is islam in the first one i'm like
i don't know anything anymore bro
after that discussion what is islam what
is the deen bro far nonhell could
probably attest to this because we just
had that class recently too
it's like i bro this is the basics what
is islam but i don't even know anything
subhan allah and ever since then it's
like it was just life-changing
subhanallah so
that class that class i learned that the
more i learned the more i realized i
don't know anything
yeah yeah yeah that's something we
talked about on the channel the kruger
effect
right when you first when you're first
introduced to anything you learn a
little bit your confidence is like 100
and then the more you learn the more you
realize you need to learn and the more
you realize you don't actually know so
your confidence just drops
and then it goes up over time maybe over
the years
it never goes back up to 100 because you
know you're just not gonna know
everything's found a lot
and that's it's even like that with like
with the basics subhanallah
the basics of taheed a lot of people
just say the the tahitis there's one god
where they worship
and don't associate parties with him and
like that's it he's like that's the
basics i know
it's like go read imam allah his book
he has like a hundred notes or something
on on you know about allah
and i was reading the first like 10 20
and i'm like like
okay i don't know anything i'm going
back to the books
i'm so glad you mentioned god bless you
that's what i mean by i mean if just
like i said just trying to be a basic
muslim
is there's a lot involved in that you
know i mean just learning
like you said i mean oh i know about
tahiti do you okay
really okay so when you start that's a
massive topic
you know learning how to pray properly
learning how to do ramadan properly and
when it's ramadan learning all the
all the the things involved both these
things
you never get to the end of it you know
you never know everything and the more
you
think you know the deeper you get in the
more you realize you
that you don't know you know but you're
right you bang on because you know when
you're young when you're young in the
dean and you think you've learned
something you want to tell everyone
but then you realize hold on i i don't
know anything really
like we're barely understanding the like
the farad and we're going for sunnah
and you know all the extra you know
recommended stuff that aren't even
obligatory
and let alone trying to put it down
other people's throats and we don't even
know the fried stuff basically
yeah yeah yeah
and this is another problem i know
there's brothers out there that want to
get into debates and arguments and
and probably they're not qualified to do
these stuff you know and nothing else
they wouldn't get into an argument about
medicine
they won't get into an argument about
you know mathematics or something but
they want to get into an argument about
religion
like leave that to the people that know
stay in your lane
know what you know learn what you know
teach what you can but when it comes to
these issues
you know muslims want to argue with all
other muslims about their own religion
and it's on points that
that are too small for them to you know
to
they're not i'm not saying they're small
points but they want to get
semantical on points and argue about
these points but you're missing the
picture
that's not making you a better muslim
that's not helping anybody
all that's doing is causing two men to
argue about something that they really
should leave up to scholars
yeah yeah yeah that's the fact that
in fact you know bro you want to go no
no bro go on man
is going to ask uh how do you draw the
line then between you know
speaking your truth and you know trying
to share with the world
but then also humbling yourself and not
speaking over other people that are more
qualified
um that took time and that that 100
that's a good question because that took
time you know because and it comes from
going back to
the point the brother said um just a
moment ago is that
you come in and thinking you know stuff
and it's only when you realize that you
don't know stuff that you end up
having to be quiet you know and um but
now
i treat everybody with this i'll give
everyone time to talk whether they know
more than well
most people know more than me but
whether they know something or don't i
give everyone a little bit of space
because
and let them talk um yeah i mean you can
normally tell when someone knows
uh you know about it about the religion
you can only tell from their
how they structure their own personality
and come across
but i i i when it comes to talking over
people brother and um
i tend i try not to do that with anybody
i even even ignorant people i try and
give them a little bit of space just to
get it out their system
just you know just so i can i can help
you maybe help on that but
i don't um i i i deliberately try and
steer clear
of debating people and arguing with p i
don't argue
actually i refuse to argue um because i
as a man i think i try and carry myself
a certain character you know and um
arguing there's three types of people
that i think argue
okay women children and people that are
in the wrong
okay now children will argue because
they're immature they don't know the
world
women bless them i don't want all the
women to get upset with me but
sometimes they i've known some women
that could start an argument in an empty
room okay they're just emotional and
argue
and people that are in the wrong will
argue to reinforce or to
try and back up their their argument or
their point if you're in the right
brother you don't need to argue
i'm not going to argue if i'm in the
right i'm just going to say bro that's
how it is if you don't like it then i'm
not going to stand there and argue with
you about it
because it's just no one wins that no
one wins an argument you know i mean so
i'll walk away i'll walk away i'll talk
walk or fight
we'll pick one you know so i don't um
i don't argue with people i i refuse to
get into these religious debates and
religious arguments and
and you know because it's not i'm not
well i'm not qualified into it doesn't
help me
if it doesn't help me it doesn't benefit
me it doesn't benefit
anybody and a lot of this stuff like i
said should be left to to people that
have knowledge
if i can't even read the quran properly
and understand it then what am i arguing
about with someone else
yeah yeah what i mean
yeah and it's the thing is that
sometimes it's hard to draw the line
right between a discussion and an
argument and sometimes it's hard to draw
the line between
i should speak you know and and teach
people about this and i shouldn't say
anything because
you know some muslims are going to use
that as an excuse right uh
just to not give dawah at all you know i
don't know enough like they just you
know sit in their house and that's it
um but you know that's not or at least
that's not what i'm saying that's not
why you know i'm
advocating for it allah i was going to
mention we actually had this discussion
on tick tock about
like this deep like al-qaeda like belief
issue
is allah like physically for a better
word literally above the arch is
a metaphor and all this stuff and
there's one group that's saying if you
believe allah is literally above the
you're not even a muslim so this is a
very you know very
drastic issue and now me myself i can
quote imam abu hanifah
like in like the english translation all
that but the bare fact that this the man
who's arguing
against you know what i believe knows
arabic and i don't
you know i would have caused a lot of
fitnah if i went on by myself to talk to
him
because he's he seems like he knows a
lot more than me because he knows arabic
you know alone
it's found a lot but when you had you
know sheikh muhammad who came on discuss
with them
it was a lot more affair of the
discussion alhamdulillah so this is the
uh
the amanda that we have when we have you
know these discussions and everything
and you know you actually reminded me of
something imam shafir allah said
you know him being a scholar he said
i've never debated an intelligent person
except that i won
and i never debated an ignorant person
except that i lost because you can't win
with people like that subhanallah
and this is something i think we all
need to be cognizant
of and the last thing i want you you
actually mentioned it you know you don't
argue and i think that's a very
beautiful thing
allah and the key word is argue because
the falsehood said he will guarantee a
house and jannah for the one who gives
up arguing even when he's right
because arguing literally has no benefit
it's literally just a waste of time
because arguing with someone
in it entails the fact that they're just
not gonna move from that position
and you're just not gonna move from your
position so what's the point
is you're throwing constant jobs at each
other subhan allah and um
there's a lot more you could do in that
time you know go read the book of tahiti
we're just talking about inshallah
xbox i was gonna ask in the last 25
years of you
you know becoming a you know practicing
muslim doing your best and now
alhamdulillah being at a point that
you're giving back and you want to
continue to give dawah
what are some of the biggest revert
struggles that you've had
um and wisdom that you can share so for
example one would be controlling your
nafs your desires
right so what are some other ones um
like i said i mean i think i mentioned
it before i am
trying to change too quickly too fast in
the early days
you know you've got to become
comfortable in your deen in your
religion you've got to feel
you've got to fit you gotta feel
comfortable and um
it's it's in the beginning i i i i was
wearing a thobe i
i grew a beard i was i was doing all of
these things and then like i said i got
a little bit
a little bit lost i got i got a little
bit like i lost my own personality and i
didn't know who i was
and that for some years confused me i
thought well if i stop doing this i'm
not going to be muslim anymore and
that for me was was was the biggest um
sort of confusion you know i i i found
myself trying to do
like i said i i think people think when
they have to become muslim or
when they become muslim they have to
change everything about themselves
instead of just being themselves
and that's a big barrier for people who
want to become muslim and two to
stay muslim you know especially when
your culture isn't islamic
now if you're coming from a background
as pakistani or african or
arab then you have a history of islamic
culture in your culture as well
okay so if i was to say like in in
england we have a lot of
muslim brothers that come from a
jamaican or caribbean background
but they'll track their their heritage
back to africa and there's an islamic
history in africa
the same with pakistan and all of that
but when you're english there is no
culture of islam here
there's no history of islam in england
you know what i mean
so we tend to adopt
another culture and and and not ours you
know and
for me i found that quite um
uh confusing for a little while but now
i'm cool with it
if you're not enjoying your islam then
you're doing it wrong
so you need to be comfortable you need
to be settled and like this is what
you're going to do for the rest of your
life
and that needs to fit you know what i
mean so i think that would take
time and how to help um the reverts do
that is that the muslims around them
understand that
and and and help them with that rather
than sort of like out of
nice intentions just trying to force
them in you know what i mean
but bring them in and put this on them
and put it out on them and you know just
just be gentle with them brother i mean
let them find there let them settle down
and let them find himself you know i
mean
yeah that's probably 100 man and also
not having
uh the the muslims like the brothers and
sisters
put down fellow riverts who are trying
their best
or maybe they um maybe their their
character is just not 100 yet
maybe they're just not speaking 100
maybe they just don't know their
intellect is just not 100
yet maybe it's a woman and she's not
wearing the hijab yet
but she's being put down because she's
showing her head
you know what i mean so i i think that's
a big point as well
because a lot of times you know the
brothers and sisters my bad couldn't you
aren't broke
but um don't have good intentions you
know but
it's it just it doesn't at least the the
person who's receiving
whatever is being said they don't they
don't receive it the way that it should
be
nam i think you're right brother i mean
a lot of the the the muslims
have good intentions with and some of
them some of them just get a little bit
self-righteous though
oh you're not wearing hijab you know
listen
she she's come from a background that's
non-islamic there's many many muslim
women that have been brought up in the
religion that were hijab i'm not saying
that it's right but give them
you know that's not going to help her to
put a hijab on telling that she's not
going to
she already knows that you're not saying
is it not better that she's a muslim
without hijab
than you know a non-muslim without hijab
you know
so just i i think you know some of the
some of the
muslims need to be a little bit
self-righteous a little bit less
self-righteous and a little bit more
understanding
and um you know as reverts brother you
know
and you're in the deen for the first two
or three years four or five years
whatever time it is it's like what
you're not gonna slip you're not gonna
swear sometimes
you're not gonna of course you are you
know it's unrealistic to think that
you're not you just spent
20 something years doing that you know
what you think you want to stop it like
this
it's i think you've got you you you
can't let your sins another thing that
used to
used to catch me still catches me but it
definitely really nearly took me out of
the religion it took me out the deen at
one point
was that i let the sins that i committed
suffocate me
like there was no way out i've done this
scene i know it's too much it's
it's i'm how am i going to get over this
how am i going to make this better
and you kind of let the sim just just
squash you
you know it just just sort of suffocate
you to the point where you just want to
escape
and you know that's that's a burden that
that i suffered from and the end is
what's the point you know if i i i can't
do it i can't handle it
and and and what i had to understand and
what i had to keep telling me it comes
back down to listening to people of
knowledge
is that allah will forgive everything
except dying upon shirk
you know what i mean so as long as
you've got this anxiety and that you
want to be forgiven and you want to do
something good and you want to make
amends for it that's a very good sign
that
allah is forgiving you i mean you know
so and that's another thing but you know
reverse they'll come in
they'll do something wrong like swear or
they can't wear hijab for whatever
reason you know that's their personal
uh struggle and then they'll off i can't
do it i can't and then i'll leave
you know then they'll go then they'll
jog on they can't do it because
they'll feel overwhelmed by that you
know so i think there's a responsibility
on the
on the muslim community around them to
uh to to understand them things as well
you know i mean
just because you hear this brother
swearing or this sister not wearing
hijab
be patient advise them but maybe even
advise them in private too many people
are fast to advise you in public
yeah you know i'm saying they want to
tell you this in front of everyone and
that
you know that that's not nice you know
i've had brothers advise me in the
masjid in front of everybody
you know when in in the in you know back
in the days and you shouldn't do this
you shouldn't do that
but there's like 50 people here you
couldn't have picked another time
you know but you know i think that them
things as well
um i mean charlotte this is this is
this one's saying just keeping it basic
is different is a job you know
i don't know yeah i mean me personally
something that i struggle with a lot
is it's myself a little bit here but
something i struggle with a lot and i
think a lot of people struggle with is
is
saying what they want to say not what
the person needs to hear
um and a lot of the time it could be the
same point
it could be the same point but you just
said it in two different ways
people need such a little encouragement
like honestly a lot of the time some
people just need
just a little bit but in the right way
and this
as you as you mentioned
self-righteousness
it's a it's a it could even be a disease
of the heart it's because it could be
tied with like arrogance in a way you
know it's coming from like an
authoritative
position not just authoritative but like
at least like you know i'm made from
this i'm like this
you're not that i'm better than you and
and not seeing them as an equal and i
think
it's really important to tie it back to
how we you know started this
conversation with what you were
mentioning
about um gauging people that's what the
prophet ali
salaam did with every individual every
person is their own specific case
and with every specific case you need to
study that case
and really you know delve deep into that
specific case
and if you don't do that then you're
doing a tremendous disservice because
you know the prophet islam
you know there are times when you know a
woman crying at a grave
like you yelled at him at least islam he
walked away
he didn't pull up the verse in the quran
that says you know don't raise your
voice to the prophet so he said he
walked away
this is the essence of emotional
intelligence and that's something
i myself really do think i've been
struggling with and you know may allah
allow me and everyone else to be better
i mean but it's like it could be
the difference between someone being
better or being worse and like if that's
on me man may allah forgive me for that
because
it was scary allah is scary but
beautiful point
may allah bless you mostly i do think
this episode is coming to a close soon
so please
um final questions comments concerns i
think this has been a beautiful
discussion
yes so you had spoken about closing the
gap
right that you said elders uh
in in the past they would transmit that
knowledge and that wisdom to
the young and nowadays that's not
happening as much
you know in your words so what do you
think
or what are you planning to do what do
you have in mind that's like
you you're going to do your part here
because you said you want to do
something
to help out you want to be able to stand
in front of the creator
so like what you got playing here
brother
i don't know bruh i'm just gonna do what
i can you know to be honest with you
um i i i can't speak for anybody else
you know i mean i can't
i can't uh i can't account for what
other people are gonna do but i i just
know that for myself
i i'm gonna try and do what i can um
that's all i that's all i can do that's
all i'm responsible for
um i i do speak to brothers now that
have been in the dean
because there's a few of us now that
have been in the dean for 25 30 years
and we've all got the same sort of it's
just age it just comes with age the same
sort of mindset now where
you know it's it's kind of our time to
give give back
it's our time to sort of say right okay
and you know it's not just muslims evil
brother you know there's a lot of lads
you know a lot of
youngsters out there that are non-muslim
okay that are getting himself into
street crimes and drugs and all this
sort of stuff but we have a
responsibility to help
everybody even if it's to stop them from
killing each other you're not saying
even if it's
stopping shooting and stabbing each
other and and all this sort of stuff
so there's there's other brothers that i
know
my friends like me that have been in the
deen 25 30 years
they have the same sort of mindset as
i'm sure some of them are doing a lot
better work than i am
but i'm just going to continue inshallah
to do what i'm doing you know i i know
nothing about social media
i know nothing about editing and cutting
and all this sort of
stuff but i'll do what i can you know if
i can
do something then i'll do something
inside and whatever allah has in plan
for me
and whatever he wants to to do some good
i was speaking to a
a brother that i know very well he's one
of the brothers i go to for islamic
knowledge
and i said brother you know some
someone's put videos out there of me
and people are texting me saying oh
brother that's you in the pic that's you
in the videos martial it's a great video
etc yeah i said but i don't want this
you know i don't want uh
to feel like i'm my reward is going to
be people saying
how wonderful the video was because we
weren't even me to put it out there you
know i mean
but he said listen he says and he give
me some advice i said i need some advice
because i was i would just stop doing
vid i'll just stop you know
he goes look he goes it's it's a type of
shirt
to do something good in order to please
the people
but it's also a type of shirt to stop
doing something good
in in order not to please the people you
know
so he said if you're doing something
good
for the sake of allah then don't worry
about what other people are saying and
whatever reaction he's having
just be thankful that god has used you
allah has used you to bring about some
good
and and just keep going just keep doing
it you know no sorry
to abandon doing something good for the
sake of the people
so if you're doing something good to get
the pleasure of the people then that's
the type of shirt if you abandon doing
something good
for the sake of the people then you know
no one would ever give out
food parcels no one would ever get
involved in charity work because
everyone that does charity work gets a
certain amount of kudos and praise
you know so they would just stop doing
it you know so you wouldn't he said
don't
abandon doing something good in order
because of the people just
keep doing what you think is good and if
i love bringing something good from it
then be happy that allah something good
from that and
and take that as a good sign you know so
for what i'm gonna do
bro brothers i'm just gonna try and do
what i can do i
i don't know a lot along those best what
the plans are but
that's my plan you know
yeah may allah put barakah
in your pursuit and your endeavors man i
mean i mean man may allah accept it and
elevate you in the highest ranks i mean
man it's so inspiring i never never
would have thought growing up you know
being told what i thought about muslims
that there'd be a you know
a white man who you know people you know
where i grew up they'd be like oh you
know they're non-muslim or the christian
i'm learning so much about my own
religion that i took for granted for 20
plus years bro
and i just want to let you know man like
we don't really see you as
a white man we're only saying that
because you said it so
we're just using it as like a reference
point i say it because his youtube
channel is i think it's dowie the white
muslim fellow or something like that
oh all right there we go bro we're gonna
plug that in the description guys
make sure you hit that subscribe button
in his channel show him some love and
watch some of his videos bro
okay thank you for that bro appreciate
it so is there anything else that you
know we can do for you anything you want
to you know
get out there no i appreciate your time
i appreciate you guys uh
calling me inviting me on for this talk
in charlotte and
hopefully allah will do something good
with it and um
i mean i mean i i mean yo you're you're
literally
open invite anytime you want to be on
just hit us up man
okay so i appreciate that man okay
pleasure and an honor may allah reward
you and i love you have you been
a beautiful episode lots of beautiful
reminders may allah allow us to embody
all of them
i mean
thank you
think about a video game think about a
movie you think about a book you have
different characters
the character is uh the expressions the
actions
the personality the traits of this
individual
good character would imply obviously
that this person leads
towards good bad would imply that they
lean towards bad but
having character in general uh implies
authenticity or at least i would say
good character implies authenticity
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
hmm